[Music]
john's with us in austin texas hi john
welcome to the ramsay show merry
christmas
merry christmas to you as well
uh so i am following the baby steps uh i
just finished big step one so i have a
thousand dollars
for an emergency fund
and i
have credit card debt left over and also
i have a car release which i promise to
you it's the last car release i'll ever
do but
uh i'm starting out because the
used car market is really good right now
so if i were to compare the kelly blue
book value of the car for the trade-in
compared to my buyout it would basically
net me a 4700 check
uh i was calling to see if i should
potentially do that or if i should
prioritize one of my lower credit cards
that i owe
it nets you money
it doesn't cost you money so how does it
compare to a credit card i'm confused
oh no uh i'm sorry i mean no you're
saying should i move it up in the debt
snowball because you got to come out of
pocket with 4 700.
no there uh it would i would end up
getting 4700 back so yeah kelly blue
book value is yeah
yeah and you would you would get rid of
a car payment and have five thousand
dollars in your pocket
and
how does that
you should do that or do a credit card
i'm confused
i'm sorry uh so basically take that
amount and then i was wondering like is
that enough to get like a decent enough
used car oh yeah or definitely okay yeah
get you a 5 000 car
okay that's a net that's a net zero that
costs you nothing towards your debt
snowball except it gets rid of your big
buck car payment
sure what do you make a year
uh about between 55 to 60k cool good
okay and how much debt do you have left
not counting this car
yeah i'm not counting the lease so a
credit card that's about 17 000 and i
have about a 5 000 personal loan that
i'm paying off
okay so 18k clears you
and how much is your car payment
uh car payment is 375.
okay cool all right so you got an extra
400 a month to throw towards the 18.
when do you project you'll be done with
the 18
without a car
oh yeah without the car uh
i know everything i've done factoring
has been including a car payment so i
mean uh i mean if i did 375 extra a
month that's
uh
yeah i don't know it would definitely
shorten
dollars a year
uh making making you said 55
uh yeah i'm 55 to 60 i do commission so
it varies i would want your debt free in
under a year
that's 1500 bucks a month
yeah
and you don't have the 375 car payment
that gets you there in a year
you can do it yeah and then i guess
probably insurance payment would
probably go down too because i imagine
insurance on a uh lower end car would
definitely go down significantly from
what i'm paying now yep
cool i guess that was an easy question
well it's a painful thing to do
but here's the thing
the way i answer these questions and the
way i look at it george is to say okay
10 years from today which of these moves
am i going to be glad i did
am i going to be glad i drove a piece of
crap 5 000 car for two years one year
while i get out of debt another year
while i save up some money finish my
emergency fund and buy a better car
um is that going to have led me towards
more wealth and more peace and more
prosperity or slogging my way through
this lease which one's going to have
done it and it's so for me it's a
no-brainer because doing it this way is
going to get you to wealthy faster
yeah
and it's in we're driving a piece of
crap for two years oh well give it a
name
old blue
you know old big red right if you got a
car that it needs a name you're probably
working their plan oh yeah and i was
just telling uh dave before before the
break about my crappy car that i'm
excited to upgrade uh now because we've
been aggressive on paying off the house
and so if you've got big goals like that
you're willing to do some things and
sacrifice and one of those is driving a
nice car you know i can live without
that for now